you are attempting to access terminal 7
at site 1 1 9 by continuing you are
confirming that you have permission to
access this file have submitted your
last will and testament to the scp
foundation hr department have said
goodbye to all of your family and loved
ones and consent to the probability of a
swift painful death you are not
currently under any threat but
continuing to access this file will
change that please look into the screen
to begin scan scan complete identity
confirmed welcome back agent william
miller you are now accessing file scp 2
7 4 4 tattletail warning the threat is
approaching rapidly you have a limited
amount of time to review the contents of
this file remember that this terminal
has been permanently contained mobile
task force members are aware of your
location and on standby but they will
likely not be able to save you it is
only a matter of time now scp-2774
is a bipedal humanoid creature with a
height of two meters its face is covered
with a torn white burlap cloth with a
large aluminum zipper across its mouth
though its true name is unknown it is to
be referred to by code name tattletail
the creature is extremely dangerous and
hostile it has been determined to target
anyone who attempts to investigate it or
learn the nature of its identity it
cannot be restrained or prevented from
reaching its target once it has its
sights set on you you cannot hide you
cannot run there is no escape the entity
is currently uncontained but steps have
been taken to limit its potential for
damage only this terminal has complete
read and edit access to the file once
someone has linked with a terminal all
members of mtf epsilon 99 are stationed
at the entrance to the containment cell
the entity may not be discussed outside
of the containment cell if you speak
about the tattletale entity outside of
this room you will be immediately
terminated once you have accessed this
file you are considered lost tattletail
was first encountered in the urtic nexus
the nexus is an underground freeport
where a number of anomalous entities
live without fear of exposure it's also
a network of underground tunnels used
for smuggling and other unsavory
business following a series of unsolved
murders and disappearances the global
occult coalition reached out to the
foundation for help a research team was
deployed to investigate consisting of
agent jamie green adam smith sammy
radcliffe
dr steven house and agent william miller
agent miller was outfitted with a body
cam which captured the following events
miller met with the rest of the team in
an underground house in the urtic nexus
inside he found a blood-stained room
thrown into chaos items turned over and
scattered across the room there was an
unidentified body found inside of the
house the deceased suffered from deep
wounds across their chest that tore off
skin and muscle revealing the organs and
broken bones beneath their face was
riddled with large bite marks and their
nose was missing entirely though there
were bits of flesh and blood all
throughout the room the nose was not
found while searching the room miller
found a blood spattered note with the
words help workers written along with a
phone number as the group continued to
investigate they suddenly heard
something moving and scratching in the
walls tension began to rise was the
killer still in their midst did they
need to act now before it had a chance
to give them the same gruesome fate
radcliffe shot at the wall and a rat
crawled out they were safe for now the
body couldn't be identified and was
classified as entity victim 12. the note
recovered from the crime scene led the
foundation to an attempted human and
non-human entity trafficking scheme
eight missing persons and creatures were
recovered from a warehouse and
interviewed this new chapter of the
investigation left the team with more
questions than answers and after an
anonymous tip the task force reached out
to an unnamed lizard man believed to be
a member of the mysterious fae who was
reported to have helpful information the
lizard informed agents miller and
radcliffe that he had seen something
troubling he couldn't remember the
specific details but a monster had come
to scp-4000
an enchanted forest and the home of the
fae and had spoken to someone the lizard
man had once known he followed them home
but found only a mangled corpse and a
room drenched in blood one detail stood
out in particular the lizard man said
that his dead friend had been robbed of
a name left a nameless husk whatever had
killed them it had erased their very
identity even the interviewee who had
once considered the victim a friend
could no longer remember who they were
this would be nightmarish for anyone but
especially a member of the fae as names
hold a great deal of importance for them
when agents radcliffe and miller
returned from conducting their
interviews they were informed that four
new anomalous murders had occurred in
their absence each body had the same
wounds deep lacerations on the torso and
large chunks of the face bitten off this
was troubling enough but even more
concerning was a series of unauthorized
changes to the foundation's employee
database which occurred at the same time
as the killings four employee personnel
files had been inexplicably deleted to
match the four unidentified bodies that
were found there was reason to believe
that these four new victims had all been
foundation personnel but no one could
remember their names and no one
recognized their faces the remaining
records confirmed that there had been
seven members of the task force
dispatched to handle these unsolved
murders four were gone lost from the
world and from collective memory now
only three remained sammy radcliffe
steven house and william miller miller
and radcliffe met to discuss this new
development and realized that they were
being hunted something new they were
investigating it and it was taking out
the research team one by one four down
three to go the remaining researchers
were ordered to return to site 119 for
round-the-clock protection and
surveillance steven house ignored these
orders and locked himself away in a safe
house located within the nexus radcliffe
insisted that she and miller followed
their orders and leave house behind but
miller refused he would not leave a man
behind not after losing the rest of the
team even if he couldn't remember them
miller made his way to the safe house
and arrived to find the door already
open he entered the building searching
for his missing colleague he called out
stephen and are you here but there was
no response his path wound between rows
of shelves down pitch-black narrow
hallways that seemed to go on forever
just when he thought steven might
already be lost he heard a loud crash
coming from up ahead he followed the
sound down the hall drawing his gun just
in case he turned to the left and saw
another open door inside there was a
small janitor's closet a bucket was
knocked over and water had spilled all
over the floor as miller scanned the
room his eyes fell on a limp body it was
steven house miller ran to his fallen
colleague's side crouching down to check
his wounds house's body was horribly
damaged with claw marks from his
shoulder to his hip there were puncture
wounds across his hands and arms and his
leg was broken twisted around until bone
showed through the torn skin afraid of
what he would find miller reached down
to check the man's pulse but a hand
stopped him steven house was still alive
he struggled to speak saying i'm not
useless
i swear i'm not and then one chilling
word run
behind miller something let out an
inhuman screech he spun around to see
what made the sound and saw a creature
lurching toward him it was tall humanoid
in shape but distinctly monstrous a
zipper across its face was unzipped to
reveal teeth stained black and red with
blood the creature jumped on top of him
knocking him to the ground he thrashed
and fought back trying to throw the
monster off of him but it sank its teeth
into his exposed forearm with a
sickening crunch fighting through the
pain miller fired his gun with his other
hand hitting the creature in the neck it
screamed and recoiled allowing miller to
climb back onto his feet and fire
several more shots the creature scuttled
up the wall toward the ceiling evading
miller's gunfire and advancing toward
him miller took a step back but slipped
in the blood on the floor and fell onto
his injured arm helpless miller watched
as the entity dove down at him snarling
and ready to devour him before it
reached him the crack of a gunshot rang
out miller looked up to see agent
radcliffe holding a shotgun she had come
to save him the two ran back into the
hall the entity closed behind them and
took cover behind a large shelving unit
as the entity approached hunting for
them they tried to determine what to do
next miller was frozen in place shaken
from all he had seen radcliffe told him
to run for the door she stepped out from
behind their cover and drew the
attention of the entity she fired
several more shots at it then turned to
see if miller had made it to safety as
miller begged radcliffe to run her
shotgun jammed she had no time to escape
no way to defend herself her words
before the monster descended on her were
you're not supposed to let me die like
this with nothing else he could do
miller ran he ran as fast as he could
cradling his damaged arm listening to
radcliffe's screams turned to wet
gurgles and then silence he made it out
of the building where a team of
foundation personnel were waiting to
usher him to safety he was taken back to
site 119 and placed under 24-hour
surveillance the entity he encountered
was entered into the system file
complete we hope it was worth it agent
miller there isn't much time left it's
coming you know that any minute now it
will creep up behind you then sink its
teeth into your skin devouring your body
and your name in one fatal blow what is
it is it simply a monster with an
insatiable appetite for human lives
perhaps it was once a human too a murder
victim left unseen and unsolved but
transformed into a creature intent on
erasing others perhaps it was an idea
made real by people's fear of it and
that is why it is so afraid of being
known if the puzzle is solved if it is
truly understood perhaps the creature
will simply cease to exist there is
screaming outside of the room gunfire
pounding on the walls protection is
wearing thin so think what was it what
is it you only have a few moments left
what will you leave behind once it takes
you maybe it was fear all the victims
were running from something hiding from
an invisible demon pain feelings of
inadequacy the sheer terror of the
unknown
everyone trying to run to deny their
nightmares and pretending that sleeping
with the lights on would be enough but
it never is the darkness always comes
here it comes congratulations agent
miller you have officially completed the
tattletail simulation you were
successful in acting under pressure
showing dedication to the mission and
the cause and valuing the lives of your
colleagues over your own safety your
results show high intelligence problem
solving and critical thinking skills the
test was administered by agent sammy
radcliffe agent jamie green and dr
steven house though your work was
impressive you have some areas for
improvement you did not follow protocol
when engaging with the tattletail entity
and you failed to prevent the simulated
deaths of radcliffe green and house
better luck next time still you
displayed admirable selflessness and
devotion to the foundation's mission of
knowledge information and containment of
anomalies you have been approved for
field work going forward now is a good
time to celebrate many others who were
given this test were not so lucky the
past 50 subjects to complete this
simulation failed under pressure and
died of heart failure when the fear got
the best of them but not you you have
the makings of a truly great agent here
at the scp foundation we'll be in touch
soon now go check out procedure 110
montauk revealed fear alone
scp-231 tail and scp-1025 encyclopedia
of common diseases for more scps that'll
mess with your head